I don't know the road here's what's
interesting so the box treated back to
12 will guess what no matter what the
Dolphins do they're going to get Minka
order 1 so that trade now for the box is
looking really nice they're at 12 and
the Raiders move back to 15 they're
dolphins at 11 any chance they go
L'Amour I don't think so I don't think
so I don't think so they have Tremayne
Edmunds available they have if they want
to go safety either of those safeties I
think I'd ever say like Minka I mean it
has to be a safety it's got to be
something on defense I know that yeah
yeah it definitely does man what a crazy
draft when you look at the Dolphins
right now they're starting safeties are
Rashad Jones and TJ McDonald yeah if you
look at their linebackers it's Kiko
Alonso Raekwon mental and Stephan
Anthony but vita vega is standing there
right out of staring us Robbie needs are
where they got lost and Donna consumed
yeah I know it to me the linebacker
thing is interesting certainly but you
know they talked highly of Raekwon
McMillan before we got hurt last year in
the preseason what's your prediction by
the way dolphins I'm gonna go view the
vet I said it in the preview show I
think they that make it if miko were
there they would take him so i'm gonna
stick with that okay what are you
thinking I'm gonna go vita van I'm gonna
go Minka as well I think I know I
thought it was gonna be vitae vita bay
as well I just think when I look at
their secondary I think they need
somebody that can just help them out all
together in a lot of few different areas
and make it could do that we also don't
know already do you it's your prediction
I think it's gonna be making Fitzpatrick
I think he's a guy that can play a
little slot corner for them he can come
down he'll Miller's nodding at me what
do you got Miller it's mica let's make a
Fitzpatrick okay can we get that sound
effect with Sims on camera please and
that is why I do let me guess your guys
grades on this one yeah I'm gonna say
Miller A+ I'm gonna say Sims in a yeah I
think I'm actually gonna I think I'm
gonna join him in A+ land we're given
too many good grades well I mean I don't
know these are guys that I liked I mean
make a Fitzpatrick I mean I know I'm not
like Johnny big board like you but I had
a major dick I had to make some sort of
a big board and I put on like number
eight or nine so I just don't understand
how a player that Nick
Sabin says when the best players he's
ever coached last Tilden 11 in the draft
for quarterbacks went yeah I get it but
it's also like in today's NFL with
safeties and corners and their
versatility in the passing game
and he ran a four for six like this girl
what we talked about it the Alabama
thing was hurting him yes I mean I heard
that from too many of you okay sorry
yep shut your mouth shut your mouth man
Tampa she just think Darwin at 12 I mean
I don't think there's gonna be any doubt
that's gonna be the guy was heard I had
been told there was great arguments
within that facility on German or mega
right so what do you feel the
differences are between both this video
one of the best players at Nick Saban
has ever coach Minka Fitzpatrick falls
out of the top ten and falls right in
the lap of a team that desperately needs
them the Miami Dolphins great value
great value one of the five best players
in this entire draft class great on the
field great off the field to his
football character some of the best in
the entire class and Alabama moved this
guy around he played outside corner slot
corner single high safety strong safety
he blitzed off the edge and sub-packages
so you're gonna get versatility I'll be
interested to see where am I am ii does
line him up where they try to make him a
corner or if they just let him be a
matchup type secondary player yeah I
mean this is a phenomenal football
player that I've been watching since
high school I mean he grew up here in
New Jersey I watched him play then he's
phenomenal I know I know what kind of
guy is he's obsessed with the sport I
mean he works at it he lives it every
day but as far as on the football field
I mean come on one of the things that
was hurting him was oh he plays so many
different positions what is he I'll tell
you what he is put him in free safety
and I guarantee he's gonna be one of the
three best free fits free safeties in
the sport he's Devin McCourty except
he's more powerful in a better open
field tackle er he's gonna be able to
play some nickel slot he's gonna be able
to cover backs and slot receivers with
man-to-man coverage and if you're
starting corner does get hurt once week
one week he can go out and play corner
I'll say this we watch the Dolphins
clear house with their leaders in donek
ensued Jarvis Landry this is the new
face of that leader shadowing gay war
leaders that's the progress that they
talked about a cold
your change this is how you do it a guy
who do you get for Clegg give it an A+
because he's been compared to Jalen
Ramsey Jamaal Adams guys who just love
football the wiring which was on our
bingo board last year of my saying his
wiring is great it's an A+ from me a
plus for me as well I mean this is one
of the can't miss prospects of the whole
NFL Draft definitely one of the 10 best
players in the draft for me so many
things he can do for your defense but
again I look at him like our guy last
year from the New York Jets Jamal Adams
Joe bottoms you put him in the box for
run situations maybe more Minka you put
him down there because he's gonna be
awesome at covering tight ends backs out
of the backfield he won the Chuck
Bednarik award and the Jim Thorpe Award
he is one of only three players to ever
do that him Charles Woodson and Patrick
Peterson and you got him at 11
mink up in my hand alright so Bucks are
taking Derwin we're gonna go side own
sink I would think I Got News for you oh
well first of all is that three people
from New Jersey in the top ten eleven
okay not bad for the grace it's not bad
I'm sorry all right what you got for us
to not Derwin this one's a shocker the
Bucks took Vita baya Wow Wow
I hate that that is that a shock for you
guys I just wasn't expecting it I mean I
look at their secondaries they are the
right weakest things on their team yeah
at the same point though yeah they were
30 second in the NFL in passing they
were 30 second the NFL in sacks 23rd
against the rush but if you look at the
inside their starter next to Gerald
McCoy was beau Allen yeah they don't
have bow-bow-bow Allen as your number
one d tackle but with all the rumors for
this whole process being safety I think
that's where it's really a surprise I
mean I would have trade it back again I
would have found a trade partner I I'm
not gonna be too mad about this facebook
comments are calling you guys soft
graders yeah I'm gonna give it a see all
right oh-ho I mean I gave the first drug
I gave the first pick of the draft a
c-minus
but yeah I mean listen these guys these
were a lot of these guys are the guys we
thought we're gonna go here they were
all the easy picks this is the top tier
of the class I mean I don't think there
was any denying this in any of our eyes
we didn't know they're gonna go in this
order but there hasn't been like
any name that's been out there yet there
we go oh wow I didn't expect this
guidance do you know what Vita veis full
name is nope not Vita via Tavita - Lea
key Oh No
- we poo loto mo sees the heya fully
towel whoa yeah that's a lot it's up
chances you got that right
I'm gonna go eh - Connor oh you're
changing it what did I skip McGrady I
know you didn't okay
so shut your mouth I want to frame it to
you like this if the Bucs secondary is
an absolute mess again and Derwin James
is one of the better rookies the NFL's
this pick a mistake no matter what Vito
Bay it does yes the only thing I would
argue dwith the Derwin James thing right
was I don't think it's a scheme that
necessarily fits him they're a what
Derwood James what is he going to be
he's in the Box a down right we all look
at that so but they had that guy they
have is what I mean so maybe that that
to me was where I was like man Minkus
seems more right for them they just they
also at every corner still available on
the board yeah Denzel Ward but V to VII
so why does this as this change the
Tampa Bay Bucs now I don't think he's
the difference maker I do I do
so do we want to wait to the video or do
we want to tell the other greats I know
but we're not doing the video video
right now okay waiting for TV let's do
it no I was just saying did you want to
talk it out right now or start the video
though save it for the video pal
Tampa Bay finished fourth in the NFC
South last year and they're starting in
the trenches to start building back up
Veta via an absolute mountain of a man
from Washington is the pick at 12 what
are you thinking of selection well I had
him at 16 overall so I think the values
a little bit off especially with players
like Derwin James still on the board and
their need in the secondary
Veta Bay is a very good player I think
he was the best defensive tackle in this
class he is a monster of a man and his
pursuit is amazing he was the best in
the class at stacking up double teams
splitting and I've said before he's a
disrupt her he's not gonna be a true
penetrator but he is a much better
athlete than you would expect for a guy
who's going about 345 yes I mean listen
I like this guy a lot I'm higher on him
than you
I think yes at 347 pounds 41 benchpress
reps I mean it's an ugly body let me
just tell you when I turned on film I
said wow he is ugly looking in that
uniform you're what that he's gonna have
an off C wall for years from now then
won't Lee negative ideas he has one bad
all seasons gonna be 390 and you're
gonna oh we need just put in a weight
plan here for him but talking about the
player right now he's extremely
disruptive he's a freak of nature on the
football field I've never seen anybody
that looks like him in a football
uniform it has that size B is disruptive
as he is him with Gerald McCoy watch out
that is gonna be some tan to the deal
disappear Paul now yes right and they've
invested in the defensive line
absolutely have you really have so
what's your great I gave it a seat I
just don't know if he can get off blocks
short arms you saw it 32 and a quarter
inch arms not great for a guy whose pad
level was inconsistent at times and I
think they're gonna regret not taking
dirt with James here well this is a 4-3
defense right I'm gonna give it an A -
okay because I do think that secondary
was a greater need for them right here
but I'm not gonna kill this pick I think
this guy is a difference maker
it's a 4-3 defense I don't worry about
the long alarms just because maybe you
won't have to hold up to got people but
man who's our defensive coordinator
there Mike Smith Mike Smith it's back to
like his Jacksonville days he's got this
huge defensive line now that can
overpower people so that makes sense
yeah this was a team that was last in
the NFL in sacks and now across the
board they go jpp Gerald McCoy Vito Vega
Vinny curry and I don't think they're
gonna be last in sacks next year hold
the pirate's life for me it does always
they have a sentimental place in my
heart
for sure yeah like I made a baby down
there all right so now at 13 Washington
what are we thinking for the for washing
Derwin Jones they just lost two of
Cravens people say he's our next Sean
Taylor I just feel like it's oh yeah
that's right yeah I had Derwent on our
podcast and you say that he gets
compared to Sean Taylor I also think
that this is the worst front office in
the NFL do you so you loose at well
Bruce Allen's definitely up
right I've never think about my purse
like that I'm sorry I have no faith in
this front office for there any other
position possibility here could they go
for a Landry or a Davenport could they
go for an Edmunds who now at Virginia
Tech right there the state of Virginia
is suddenly available at third I mean
they could go corner again to me they
can also do tackle like I bet you they
were a team to go Dan I think Saturday I
just left off the board because they
have not had that I mean there's no
great NFL and stopping the run let's
take a look at Matt and they have
Jonathan Allen right yes who was injured
for some right are waiting to see his
full capabilities but safety leaning
back and I this is lose big bore lot
athletes Edmonds has fallen
Derwin James is there Connor Williams
but yeah Davenport Landry James Edmonds
that's athletes go Lou yeah and guys who
are a little role a trained Edmonds is
young and still figuring out when you
look at the secondary of Washington
right now they have Josh Norman Orlando
Scandrick I know you like Fabian morose
I did yeah but it's safety it's DJ swear
injure and the other starter right now
deshays irreverent yeah
Kerwin James is the picture I would
think so it makes too much sense to me I
mean value at this biggest baby I mean
listen I I you know maybe they pare
Jermaine admins of them I got you got a
better breed defense that's all it has
to be deep Derwin James you just lost
sua Cravens right because he decided to
quit on the team and now he's on the
Denver Broncos
Tremayne Edmonds with Zac Brown yeah
well they have a very good I mean they
have a lot of talent on the outside with
Preston Smith yeah their holes are at
safety and defensive tackle yeah pretty
man the defensive tackle went and the
safety still there's I mean it's a when
gyre Alexander or somebody like that I
wouldn't be mad at I'm I would get it
yeah but yeah the other guys you were
talking about left coast the only other
hole that I see that's glaring on this
team but I think the value is there is
at the center or guard position yeah I
lost Shawn Laval I think early for that
that's what I'm saying the value is not
there but you lose Shawn Laval you lose
your center Spencer long but I don't
think you can reach for a will Hernandez
or somebody right now no
and they're all lines still pretty good
I don't look at it as like desperate I
guess yeah it's a good sheriff and you
have Trent Williams yeah and Morgan
Moses is good yeah I it should be James
but we thought that with him Sherwin
what's the great anything hey oh yeah
there durman's definitely gonna Derlin
it was more uh you know when I had to do
my top twenty board Durbin was like
right on my fringe of ten or eleven I
think I had a mad so so it's not Wow its
defense all right let's do the ding and
I want Connor he looks disappointed
Connor I am get it I'm fine heat this
front oh I thought this guy would go
outside of I thought he'd go or a top
around to Doron Payne defensive line out
okay so I want to say something you know
where Doron pains from Alabama this
front office can't evaluate talent so
they just go let's just take a kid from
Alabama that we did it last year they do
it John Allen I think you guys are
freaking wrong I think drop because I
think Robins really good I think he was
really good against Clemson I mean I
liked a period I daddy Connor okay d4
dumb I'm excited cuz I know a lot of
friends that Doron Payne spends a lot of
time in the Washington area and I think
this is amazing
but Jerrod pain so you're saying that's
a little bit overrated
Connor sisal overrated Simms you're
disagreeing here I am I really like
Tehran pain I thought he was definitely
in one of the 20 best players of the
draft I mean Iran pain when I watched
him I thought the things I've wrote I
wrote this is Co on sort this is this is
gonna be one of the better defensive
tackles in football for me you know he
just he had a little bit of everything
he's kidding he can be the guy that can
make a mosh pit of the run game and take
on double teams and he can be disruptive
to I really liked him when your grades
I gave it a D what did you give it Sims
I am going to give it an a oh and this
is why I was so happy that Susan Miller
didn't do you want me to read just like
my little thing by before it become now
I'm gonna make the video and read it so
we got all this time we got no
commercials shut up here we go I wrote
just talking we're at the video anyway
I'll find it start no I just say I mean
powerful-looking DT body is not perfect
like Seward Donald not quite as
fortunate but man the kid still has a
good body you could tell he's thick with
dense muscle it's not mush
let's see not far in I already impressed
the paint already - anything in the
interior D line I wrote he can be three
four or four three he can definitely -
gap because he's strong as hell but I
think he would really thrive in a 4-3
nose tackle or three technique situation
exactly then what did you see Miller
that was different from what Simpson
three sacks in college that's it but is
that were they asking him - yeah I mean
it's Alabama scheme you're I mean there
were times he was asked to be a cog and
a little bit and just take on blockers
but he was a flash player one year
starter so that's a concern for me and I
know they had talent there but just a
one-year starter and I just don't see
him as the type of consistent player
that you draft in the top I think we
have to be careful with the Alabama guys
at times this is my assistant I'm not
yeah we're hip we'll see in two or three
years whether who's right or wrong to me
though with the Alabama guys you've got
to be careful in the d-line because
they're never they never take the reins
off very rarely are they allowed to just
go I want to say this also the say no
it's got a tree it up to 14 with the
Packers if Lamar Jackson is with Sean
Payton and under Drew Brees I think
they're gonna go Harold land I think
they're gonna pass rush yeah okay well a
good dream I just want the Marv Jackson
alright so don't go alright so you you
do your whole Alabama spiel - when we do
this we're gonna do a video right now
you forgetting who we're talking about
you're on pain
[Music]
Washington was sitting there at 13 and a
lot of good players fell I know there's
been surprise here that they went Doron
Paine defensive lineman out of Alabama
not so high on him super high on him so
you're getting the full gamut why are
you not that high under on paper I think
you look at a defensive lineman about
three sacks in college that's a problem
for me and he was a flash player who
looked great against Clemson we didn't
see him do much the rest of his career
so he is an upset guy
I had him ranked 34th overall I thought
he was a second round player and we saw
here a guy who's probably a nose tackle
go 13 overall when Derwin James was on
the board the their safeties are so bad
I liked her on paint I really do I just
don't like him this early in a draft
that has pretty good depth to defensive
line where you could have taken out
Harrison Phillips in round two and got a
difference-maker at Durham James all
right now the positive derived yeah I
really like Doron Payne I mean I just
look at Doron pain first of all you got
to think about this with Alabama guys
Alabama defensive line they're never
allowed to just tend their backs and go
Vick Saban they to gap they make them
read everything hold up your defender
then discard and go when he's allowed to
go when they played one gap schemes like
a 4-3 temp scheme at times of time man
he can win with athleticism he stout
enough to take on double teams he could
be a three technique or a shade nose I
mean listen he's 311 pounds and he ran
for nine five two so that tells you he's
got an explosion I am a big fan of the
guy I think there's a lot of things he
can do for your interior prodigy
freshman in high school yeah he was a
300-pounder that could dunk a basketball
he's one of those guys yeah what is your
grade this is gonna be interesting as a
freshman high school you get dunk as a
deal I'm in a color couldn't sack the
quarterback I'm gonna give it a D there
were so many better players on the board
again 34th overall I think it's a reach
he'll be a good player he'll be solid
but I don't think he's a transcendent
talent that you take this early I'm
giving it an a I think he will be a
dominant player I look at him as almost
like a co Bonjour me and Miller are
we're different here I thought he was in
the conversation with one of the 20 best
players in the draft and I evaluated him
Hey the Redskins we've talked about it
for years they had to get bigger and
more physical in the middle at least
they're doing that I can give him credit
for that Washington was the last the
worst team in the NFL in stopping the
run and they're hoping that Duran brings
the pain at
[Laughter]
I can get the simple Sims laughs that's
all I want
all right what are the trade details for
the Saints moving up to 14 from 27 like
a lot baby cuz they gave up their first
rounder this year their fifth round pick
and their first rounder next year Wow
yeah
so you're thinking Landry it makes me
think but I just say this is so good
this is me my thing the Saints have to
be in what mode right now we're never
super well when the Super Bowl they're
playing for the Super Bowl they really
need a password I think that's where I
go out so I think pass rusher but i mean
i i'd heard pass rusher all along i did
but that was also at 27 so let me ask
you yeah is it Marcus Davenport or is it
Harold Landry who fits into that scheme
better I think Harold Landry - totally
different - Carol Landry as well I think
Harold Landry with the guy but hasn't he
been so fun but yeah
what is the difference for everybody out
there between those two guys
I mean Landry smaller he's built like
Cameron wake and his move is that
shoulder dip accelerate with really
really smooth hips he's a bender
Davenport is he wins with first step
quickness and length a little bit more
that and and but he is a developmental
guy he's he's probably going to play on
third downs right away so I think Landry
is just much cleaner as okay come in and
play right now Landry I think has a
higher up side just because of what he
can do coming off the edge he's excuse
me he is a special first step ability to
bend his body and put it in positions
that you can only see elite pass rushers
in the NFL do he can get in positions
where I could go Oh only the von
Miller's and the Khalil max and some of
the other top-tier pastors in the league
can do so I look at that I look at a
Harold Landry his ability to handle the
Tynan and the line of scrimmage set the
edge it's all very good the seen the
last year's films gonna want you wanting
more yes but then when you go back to
the year before when you let Kyle
trouble on sacra you guys will you guys
16 and a half you guys help me here is
there any chance that this is for Lamar
amazing because were there rumors that
Sean Payton really liked Lamar Jackson
yes and the reason I want Lamar to go
I saw a team like this I know it's very
unlikely is Lamar is gonna be judged so
critically and if he gets to work under
Drew with Sean but I understand what
you're saying they need to win now yeah
my pick yeah in it sorry
it would be awesome let's go it'll
surprise you a little bit
they took Davenport yeah okay they took
the guy that has more upside than Landry
but is not as close as him in terms of
being a pure sack mask now Sims in our
mock draft Sims had Davenport going six
so you see a special seal I mean listen
the only thing that misses from
Davenport's game is special Bend around
the edge which is what Landry would what
Landry had you got four grades last year
would scare me great b-plus for me oh
man what am I gonna give this you know
what I'm gonna mmm I'm gonna give it an
A - so you like this guy I do like this
guy yes I do I have from the start when
you look at this team they got cam I
think he's a very safe pick to like I
don't think yours no way you're getting
a bust you might not get Harold Landry
15 sacks a year which he could be
capable of yeah but I think he's gonna
be disruptive and a pain in the ass it's
tough because this team was gonna rely
on Alex Okafor and hey Olli kikaha
and both of those guys got hurt you need
a guy in there they can get after the
quarterback because this is a Saints
team look they were seventh in the NFL
in sacks last year but I don't know if
that was gonna happen if they didn't
take this guy this year he just he's
still figuring everything out okay and
that's the key they're small so I told
the story before we saw him at the
Senior Bowl on day one I was like this
is the guy for what he's talking about
mmm day two you were like okay and then
day three you're like holy hell this
yeah this guy's amazing my comparison
for him was Alden Smith with no off
field that's really good let's do this
video then Alden Smith
if there wasn't a Minnesota miracle the
Saints maybe could have made a Super
Bowl run and they're trying to make
another one trading a future first and
their current first up to 14 and taking
a pass rusher that's got size and speed
Markus Davenport tell people who this is
because I don't think many people watch
Texas San Antonio the small school guy I
remember when a scout text me said I
just watched this kid at UT San Antonio
and he's a first-round pick and I
thought the guy was drunk but guess what
he's a first-round pick he was number 14
on my board overall so great value as
you see how is he stand up he looks like
a small Ford and my comparison for him
I've said it a million times people are
tired of hearing it was Alden Smith his
combine numbers or Jadeveon Clowney so
he is a rare athlete it's just you got a
coach the guy up but you know the Saints
had a legendary historic draft last year
yes if they like this guy I'm not gonna
say anything bad about to pick because
they're probably right well yeah I mean
there's a lot to like about the guy when
you're 6 6 264 pounds and you run four
or five man there's just not a lot of
people on planet there you go how you
like them apples but hey the only thing
that's missing from this guy's game is
Elite bend around the edge physicality
smashing in one side of the offensive
line in the run game playing with a
motor
everything is their length on the arms I
think he's one of the safer picks in the
draft I really do he's certainly one of
the top 20 players in the draft for me
and what did they do last year man they
went in and fixed this defense with a
lot of draft picks I know they got Alvin
Kamara hey and he was a great player for
them but they were aggressive fixing the
defense and it paid off and got a more
and of course Marcus Williams right good
picks what grade you get for Davenport
at this spot and factoring in the trade
so the trades the only reason I'm giving
this a b-plus because it would have been
an A pick for me but they gave up a lot
they're not gonna have a first-round
pick next year they're probably betting
that that pick is gonna be 32 overall
though I am giving it I believe it what
did I give it an a-minus hey yo hey
nailed it yes good hey - I wasn't sure
there but yes I am I mean yes they gave
a lot but I'm not gonna be mad at this
picker for them trading up a lot
Drew Brees has got two years left
they're trying to win the Super Bowl
this year and next year this was the
most glaring need on their team and they
might have this is I thought he was
DeMarcus Ware coming out okay so I
thought he was pretty good we'll see how
it works out all right
I'm Worland you had an amazing year last
year like you said dominated the draft
yeah let's see if they locked in another
future superstar with the 14th pick and
Marcus Davenport the Raiders take a lot
more chance right
it's pretty shocking both are there yeah
right now ok so that thought der wien
Derwin James was top 5 player the best
player in the draft I had people tell me
and things like that
I mean people I respect them I wouldn't
just throw out crap that I don't know I
mean I I know one thing I I think it was
late in the season I tweet he was like
man Dermot James does not look the same
this year and he was coming back off a
knee I wonder if there was something
with that that you know you got falling
down a little right so if I'm looking at
the Raiders right now I don't know if
you pair up Landry with Khaleel Mac of
course Tremayne Edmonds this is a team
that needs desperate athletes with
linebacker position to take care of
Landry and then of course there's all
the quarterbacks this is a team that
really doesn't have corners and everyone
other than Denzel Ward is still um I
think my man Johnny would love him some
juror Alexander attitude on his defense
I will tell you that much so the gyre
Alexander clip yeah when they're playing
I think it was Florida State and he
popped up and he was like this behind
him have you seen that close oh it's the
Disney got flag though is it that's the
issue with him yeah alright so what's
your guess here pal we talked about
offensive tackle all along and they
McGlinchey is gone so I think it's
Colton Miller oh are you hearing
something you know Tom cable loves
Colton Miller okay so so you think
there's things you hear throughout I'm
gonna go Tremayne Edmonds I can't
believe Tremaine Emmons is still here to
be honest that's too smart for them I
heard Kay got the pick guys all right
I'm gonna go Tremaine Edmonds - alright
he's gonna Connor my board a lot of
people were onto this one but they went
with Colton Miller their offensive line
some help a guy that says are you rule
on time out I got a thorough challenge
flag Sims you think Miller is cheating
yes that's okay no one takes me my
letter X is all over tweet whatever you
got so many tabs
Tom cable saying the Tom cable thing was
real
that's our early well that's fine yeah
you're right I mean you're still
cheating is good information to that Oh
Miller cheats yeah you guys think it
every year I don't care
but don't you do it really well because
you'd be like I don't know top cable
old Miller you said cold Miller UCLA
right so plugged in I'm sorry that you
can't handle I gotta give it a beat
yeah I'm gonna give it like a b-minus my
block I just want to say something yes
this is my least favorite pick in the
draft and it's not even close I would
say to this Pilate think it's up there
with me horrible well Baker may feel
that one is up there too
man I can actually change my grade yes
I'm gonna leave my B - I want to go see
- was it falling off that far because
Tom cable can't evaluate talent I dare
you I don't we'll get to hear my real
opinions of NFL coaches on the Facebook
live thing you to be are like man you're
kind of a dick yep oh and you just curse
together I don't care that's cursing no
trick can I get her daddy's cursing
that's good never mind safe no it's no
good
yep male parts are not good don't say it
again okay it's interesting too is it's
like what's the place is one Fidel
Alexander at right tackle is he ok
wonder know they had a marshall new
house last year yeah he said they won't
start he's left tackle yes I know
another team a team picking the top ten
thought Colton Miller was the best left
tackle in the dress is that right I
don't I didn't see it I didn't either I
just enjoy the gentleman he's getting
just hitting the teeth right
the Raiders trade back there was talk to
they Michael offensive line and they
were able to get some pics in the
process 15th they go the UCLA product
Colton Miller and we have some mixed
reviews up here even though you're
saying that Tom cable like this guys
with Tom cables guy coming out of the
combine that was what I heard and he is
a very good athlete
my comparison for him was Nate's older
but I had him 32 overall my board he is
a work in progress he's a great athlete
he dominated every drill at the combine
I'm sure they're gonna show you his
numbers and they're gonna look pretty
but there's a reason Josh Rosen was one
of the most hit quarterbacks in the NFL
last year so I see him as a work in
progress and I also have zero faith in
Tom cable because I saw him do this in
Seattle yes drafting guys who they still
have one of the worst offensive lines of
football valid points certainly all of
those yes cold Miller I mean he from a
body standpoint he is your prototypical
left tackle I mean with that size the
length everybody you heard everybody
compare him to Nate's older and the NFL
Draft all that but he does play high
he's not a great run blocker that would
be one thing I look at and yes his
anchor is questionable I mean I would
worry about him the first time the
Denver pass rushing dual got a six yard
head start and came in to his chest and
whether he can actually hold his ground
permitting Derek Hall and his center of
gravity absurd well it is right and he's
still he's gonna get bigger and all that
the thing I do like though it was a true
position of need for the D Oakland
Raiders and they have given Derek Carr a
lot of money and he's the quarterback of
the future yes great for this pick I
know you think it's a reach yeah it is
reach I gave it a c-minus and I was just
reading my notes like while Chris was
talking let's scout told me this guy
soft he's not gonna be ready to play
right away he's a work in progress man I
just don't I don't like it C - yeah I
give it a b-minus but that would be my
concern Miller I mean that was the the
thing I wrote in my notes is you know
doesn't play the game with a physical
edge he's not nasty but it was a
position of need he does have potential
to be that franchise left tackle I mean
he's going to be but he's just not the
perfect prospect yet and we are getting
to that point in Donald Penn's career
where he's gonna have to be replaced and
they haven't had a really a right tackle
for the last two years
protection for John Gruden's offense hey
he's my kind of guy Miller the pick for
the Raiders down there 15
we have a trade another one
well bills move up they've got the
details remain the Ravens get the 22nd
so they switch from 16 to 22 and it's a
swap of a third for a fifth so really
not that much for the bills to move up
what do you think the bills are moving
back up to get it's got to be an
offensive lineman no I mean the middle
linebacker thing is you know this is
Shawna Jermaine and no press around
anymore
if the bills leave this draft with Josh
Allen and Tremaine Timmons and get very
strong best athletes in this trap yep
they fired on my friend so I don't know
I won't have this one you know I mean
got the pit guys Oh mommy got a new
member
it's Tremayne Ed McMahon the bills
killing it man I want to say this I
questioned the bills a lot when they
were getting rid of all of their players
or the last few years where there was
the Sammy Watkins and all those moves
but man it's worked out they know the
type of team they want it's a super
power based in your face and to get the
speed of Tremayne Edmonds on the back
end to get him at this spot is crazy
it's crazy
I mean it's racist but this was my
ultimate man crush to the whole jury
yeah he was up there for me as well and
and really to me is just the epitome of
the modern day yes NFL middle line this
is what you wanted to be for yeah
Kuechly Thomas David except he's like
he's a lot taller and longer and bigger
it's just gonna be this is again like I
look at where I would say like Josh
Allen is the modern-day Troy Aikman I
would go like this guys like your
modern-day okay so let's say Luke
Kuechly I mean this is what people are
gonna look for now that blank feed
variables this modern-day also they need
a went like all the a pluses I can have
he's replacing tunner viejo oh you can
give me an A+ still my soft a-plus this
team was 29th in rush defense I think
that's gonna change the both a-pluses
yeah I'm really impressed you're wearing
your favorite shirt though every other
day we do a podcast he wears this shirt
so it's a
color of a team that just won the Super
Bowl Philadelphia Eagles have you heard
of them huh it doesn't look that green
sure made headway Wow
Jemaine Evans well I love this a right
you know what I think there's a reason
when when Shawn McDermott took the bills
job and Brandon bean came with him
those guys were both in Carolina
together and you know that they were
probably getting together and go man if
we ever get a crack at this to build her
own team they're just always I think
that's that because of like you said
they they came into a clean house and
they still made the playoffs yes I think
that's why they have a little bit of and
almost beat the Jag they have a little
bit of a leash to take these objects in
Josh Allen and Tremaine Edmonds instead
of all we got to get Josh Rosen in and
roll Quan Smith yes no they can take
guys that need some time because they do
have a cushion built in because they
were so successful last year and that's
my rant that was good exciting Thanks
I do like this draft a lot for the bills
and I'll tell you what the fact that he
gets star Lou to laylee in front of him
- yeah it was a good free pick hi
Williams who's still somehow playing the
bills are moving and they're shaken
earlier they traded up for Josh Allen at
a position where many people thought
maybe Tremaine Edmonds would go but they
get this guy at 16 and we're up here
talking about him like he's a
generational talent tell him how good
this though I had him number four on my
blog buddy he's a really good talent he
turns 20 next week that's how young he
is he could play anywhere on defense
I've compared him to Anthony bar Brian
Urlacher he's just an athlete and this
is where the NFL is going if you want to
run a spread offense this is the guy who
can take away all those rush lanes he
can come off the edge as a pass rusher
he could carry tight ends up the seam
again number four on the board and you
just got him at 16 I might have been a
bill fan Chris yeah I mean he's one of
my main crushes of the draft I'm with
you I mean this is one of the best
specimens in the draft as well and the
player fits the scheme need as well I
mean this is Shawn McDermott he came to
the Carolina Panthers it's Thomas
Davis's Luke Kuechly athletic middle
linebacker athletic middle linebackers
this guy is them but bigger
I mean faster stronger longer everything
you want I've never seen a kid like this
no
it's truly unbelievable and I know guys
I've said this to you before I got a
chance to play against Brian Urlacher
once when you have that size of a middle
linebacker that athletic in the middle
of the field it's extremely intimidating
for a quarterback to throw the ball in
that area cuz you just go wow he's
really fast wow he's really lie he's a
true middle linebacker great pick yeah
so I know you were gonna give a good
grade really wherever he went yeah to
get him at sixth oh my gosh so really
only gave all my third-round pick and
you get fifth in exchange yes
how many pluses can you guys put next to
migrate here give this an a.1 well I
would have put seven pluses but if I
could he's one of my favorite players in
the entire draft yeah a plus here all
the way I mean again this is a position
of need for the Buffalo Bills it great
importance this position to the success
of Shaun McDermott's defense they had
nothing like this at the position it
makes sense and he has the type of size
and athletic ability in at the age like
Miller said he has Hall of Fame
potential this type of guy when I look
at him yes I'm saying I know how much
Simms cares about mom athletics his mom
was a college hurdler his dad a two-time
Pro Bowler for the Miami Dolphins right
iswhat Tremayne gets to face the
Dolphins two times a year the bills they
got athletes right now look out for that
next season oh okay so the bills are one
of those teams I'm just gonna say this
as a Philadelphia fan where you go
through all of those years of not
winning a Super Bowl I always like felt
the bills you know what I mean losing
all those Super Bowls and now that
they're sort of turning the page I'm
happy for Bills fans man I am too man I
want to see them successful and Bill's
have one of the best fan bases in
football easily who the craziest
definitely okay so the Chargers are at
17 my prediction is easy my prediction
is Lamar Jackson last year Chris Sims
told me if I'm correct they wanted to
take to Shaun Watson but Phillip Rivers
said I'm not ready to be a mentor just
yet and I was correct with my shot
mahomes than a swan is a so let me ask
you something I know that the Chargers
met with them and they love them rest
yes they did now this is a team like the
Saints who's very close to maybe making
a Superbowl run
and they could use some other pieces
safety is still sitting there
Derwin James is still sitting there but
I like their secondary Lamarr but this
might be the one guy that could trump
Lamar for them Derwin James yeah I mean
because this is Gus Bradley and he's
trying to get kam chancellor and that's
what Durbin James can be so that's right
I mean and I'm sure see yeah all these I
jumped behind them going damn I hope
they don't take German James we'd like
art and I saw Derwin Mach 2 the Chargers
and a few I did as well right right I
really thought this might be a spot for
beat avail but yeah if Darwin's there
has to be yeah they certainly could do
there's no D tackle of value here I know
I kind of had pencil them in with a deer
on pain I think one of the offensive
linemen were here maybe like if a tackle
I wouldn't go guard here ya know and I
also don't think I don't know where this
notion that the Chargers offensive his
bad started I don't get it I would just
take Darwin James just be really happy
ah you don't kiss again you you take it
huh there it is it's here it's in my boy
finally Darwin James Irwin there he is
makes too much sense Cowboys got to be
pretty disappointed right now right I
think that all those two teams after I
think the Seahawks and the Cowboys right
now are going we were so freaking close
yeah I don't think the Cowboys were as
desperate I think that one I think the
Cowboys are sitting we're about to get
our pick up any Rashad Evans or DJ more
the two thinner you know your receiver
right yeah I'm Sean Evans I mean I mean
there's a pick away but I think it'll be
van der dude I'm excited for Derwin
though because they're this is a thing a
lot of people and Derwin has been
sitting there and he's thinking about
all the money he's lost he's going to a
contender he's living in LA and he's
playing on a defense in which the
quarterbacks being pressured by Bosa and
Ingram and he gets to be on the back end
collecting it and he's playing with like
a Jason Verret yeah this is a perk this
is a lot this is my favorite tea other
right so he's locked in between them
yeah
look out for the chargers right now
before the season the Chargers were at
about 20 to 1 to win the Super Bowl so
we're the Saints throw like $100 on make
two g's and then send me on your back
don't bet on Sam Darnell being the first
pick in the draft wait so wait this is
what I wanted to say this
stuff is moving so fast I can't even
keep up it's ten minutes I think it's to
the fifties the thing of the Ravens
trading back the Ravens are definitely
one of the teams that are interested in
our boy Lamar they are yeah they say he
went to where they went to 22
what are grades under what your
brother's a little more a plus a plus
yeah I'm going a plus two so I'm just
gonna say this before we get to this
video we are at 21 and 22 I'm very
afraid for my man Lamar Jackson at 21 is
the Bengals I don't want Lamar to go
there at 22 is the Ravens I do like that
situation for Lamar Jackson because I
like the front office
I like the coaching staff right and I
know that their OC has worked with Mike
Vick before when he was in Philadelphia
so I'm really worried that he goes to
Cincinnati I just don't trust bill lazer
I don't like the system right but not
gonna buy quarterback anytime soon so
good Andy you'll get bill laser fired
and they'll bring somebody in and Lamar
I'll take over the next guy came out
this morning was that Seattle is a trade
back spot like we've talked about it all
right I think someone could come up
right now for a quarterback but for
somebody yeah I would expect Seattle
they don't have her many picks they've
been talking about trade now forever
we're ready to do Derwin awesome hey
Conor flex for me give me some biceps
there are certain players when it drafts
going on you look at them and you go why
is this guy falling no one has any issue
but teams just don't need him for some
reason well Derwin James just fell into
the lap of the Chargers at 17 a dominant
defense just got real nasty there's no
way that you could have predicted he
fell this far no I mean there were times
where I thought maybe he goes around 15
just because of when he runs in these
scenarios the quarterbacks gonna go
really couple offensive tackles are
gonna go early but I am surprised he was
still here I think it's a great spot for
him it's a great tick for the LA
Chargers I had him as the number 11
overall player on my board so to get him
a 17 and to fill arguably the biggest
position needed for them their run
defense was awful last year I think he
can really help in the box and you see
84 tackles he was coming back from a
knee injury that took almost all of his
2016 season so he's still shaken off
some of the rust he's a phenomenal
football player I mean the San Diego Los
Angeles chargers excuse me they just got
their camp Chancellor Gus Bradley your
defensive coordinator he came from
Seattle he runs the same Seattle scheme
and now you got cam chancer except he is
a lot better than camp Chancellor was
coming out of college I'm just gonna
tell you that this guy special he was
definitely one of the 10 12 best players
in the draft
yeah Miller's right it didn't work out
with team needs and the quarterback and
all that but he will knock your head off
if he is gonna be a leader in the locker
room and he's gonna give this defense
attitude all right LEM got the grade for
Derwin at seven man this is honestly one
of my favorite picks the entire draft so
far I give it an A+ Phil's in need I
also think he's just like the right guy
to sell some tickets out there with yes
let's be honest they need to do he's
gonna look sweet nose powder blue he's a
heck of a leader yeah a plus all the way
I mean again it was certainly a position
of need for the Los Angeles chargers the
defense certainly needed some help in
the middle to slow down the run game you
got a guy that's gonna be a physical
presence gonna be able to man up some of
the good pass catching tight ends in
football he is certainly going to
improve that defense all together that's
secondary Barret Heyward King and now
we're adding Derwin James he's going to
be the cams
Chancellor for the Chargers hey Chargers
you better sell out that stadium this
year because about to be the lid so we
have ourselves a trade Packers come back
up man it better be for heraldry the
Packers have the Seattle's pick it's
gotta be Landry yeah I mean I'm not
saying like it will be but it should be
they need pass rusher it's like crazy so
let me ask you so other than Landry I
feel like once we get through Landry I
feel like we've got through our blue
tapes pretty big drop-off I feel like
once we get through Landry now we're in
the wide receivers at the top we're at
the corners at the top we're at the
offensive linemen at the top and I think
rashon Evans is there but I think
between Landry and Evans there was a
pretty large gathers the big board for
you yeah yeah because like I look at
Connor Williams it's it's it depends on
well I'm actually a little surprised
because we're did this pick pick 18 and
I mean all the top 10 guys are off
they're all off and and I think durin
was the last falling-down guy but Harold
was the last guy that we thought could
possibly be a top ten yeah I really
never bought into him top ten Oh only
because of the position yeah just like
we see McGlinchey going higher than we
thought
I thought maybe Landry could go higher
because pass rushers are hard to find
that's right I have one of my things I
wrote in my notes for Harold Landry I
wrote 20 through 32 but because of the
position and being light at the position
in the draft yeah you might get over
draft like a lot of my friends in the
like draft industry put gyre Alexander I
think J Alexander is definitely a
possible as well for Mike swap they
swapped a seven for a third so the
Seahawks are getting a third rate very
moving well there was a talk about the
trade value chart changing yeah and
because they added the compensatory pick
because you trade them so now with more
picks I wonder if they lose a little bit
of value but your final predictions
you're going Landry know you're gonna go
joy year did you just cheat on us okay
no my Tina look my big boards been up
this whole time I don't think it has
been I don't know if I can plug other
it's got Jeter you know this guy more
you think he's cheatin I can't tell all
right hoping final guesses you're gonna
go line
you're gonna go try your yeah cuz that's
what are you going I'm gonna go Landry
I'm gonna go joy here I'm gonna go to
cheater well you picked you picked
wisely to cheat because it's giant I
know Daniel Jeremiah had this and he
knows Greenbay better than anyone okay
it's like when I see him say like every
year whoever he says green base taking
I'm yeah Sims you this is your I feel
like this is your favorite corner I
think overall I actually think maybe
Mike Hughes is a little bit better than
you actually had my cues going to the
Packers yeah for Jasmine I love ya I
like Jagga hogs in or better than Denzel
word I'm excited for this guy because
there needed it they had Kevin King who
they took last year in the second round
but they're relying on Truman Williams
who has not lived up to that one good
year Quinten Rollins and Josh Hawkins
they need corners as Simms likes to say
they're playing Matt Stafford Kirk
Cousins and Mitchell true risky
you need corners are your grades for
junior I'm gonna give it a B+ I'm going
to give it an A+ whoa a little bit about
the knee I'm not a doctor doctor doctor
you didn't think so
no like I mean his short area quickness
is great I didn't see like recovery
speed no sir I love how cocky this kid
is he is a dog I love it give him that
the Packer started at 14 they bounced
around and they get a corner that I know
the guys up here really liked and when
you run Mike Patton's defense you need
some quarters Matt Miller the value of
getting him trading back and getting a
minute yeah I loved what they did here
moving around the board and not giving
up a ton to come get one of the best
corners left and a guy who can play
inside or outside he has speed he is
aggressive at the line of scrimmage he
can help you out a little bit in the
slot sees the ball well one of my
biggest concerns with him I went to see
him play against Clemson and he was hurt
and it was seems like every time I tried
to Scout him this year he was hurt with
a knee injury
that I know some teams have flagged so
his numbers this past year weren't
indicative of the type of talent he is
but I had him 24 on the board and that's
with an injury concern so he is a very
good player a phenomenal football player
I would look at it like this first of
all Green Bay Packers fans you got Mike
Pettine as your defensive coordinator
what's his history Oh New York Jets what
did he have a corner that could live on
an island this guy can live on an island
he can now do creative things with the
rest of his defense he doesn't
necessarily need a pass rusher he's
creative Rex Ryan blitz package so I
look at the gyre Alexander and go man
this guy can match up with any receiver
in football he's got attitude his speed
his short area quickness is as good as
you're gonna find in this whole draft
but asked about junior Alexander his
college coach Bobby Petrino said what
Lamar does for the offense J ear does
for the defense pretty big claim that's
your great I gave it a B+ like I said
I'm just a little worried about the knee
and I know Krista said he's not a doctor
I'm not either but talking to people
around the league I think there's a
little bit of concern but you know the
Packers have been very aggressive I like
what the new front office is done yes I
I definitely do - I'm gonna get a plus
this is one of my favorite players in
the draft I think he's better than I
think he's gonna project better to the
pros and Denzel Ward who was a number
four pick I know I might be crazy and I
understand that but he fits what they
needed he's got a super attitude as far
as a corner that's gonna be in your face
and brain attitude the defense yeah he's
a playmaker and let's not forget he
returned he could be one of the best
punt returners than the NFL next year
and I don't know if Trevor Davis was
gonna be that guy but Green Bay moved
around and they got one of the best
corners and some picks to go with
Packers
hey you're Alexander cool I just saw
Jerry Jones on the phone Dallas is gonna
make this a whole spectacle because
they're a bunch of anything now is who
likes the Cowboys I do it was good when
the Cowboys are good
I like Cowboys I root for Jason Garrett
I like Ezekiel and I so Dallas gets rid
of Dez yeah and the whole talk is will
they get Calvin Ridley I know that you
like DJ more more than Calvin Ridley
here I did it definitely wider so for
the Cowboys no remember Sean Evans and
my Tommy on the guy out there they go
whole week there we go defense so I
think it's late and Vander ich you think
as long as he medically okay hands are
in the air I haven't touched never know
what play him at what middle linebacker
yeah and put Jalen at strong okay what
is with them in white linebackers I
don't know well listen linebacker
certainly in need I mean linebackers
Arnie Jalen with the nerve damage in his
knee okay we're still not sure he's ever
gonna be that guy why not take Rashad
Evans that you know is a like a
guaranteed lock I mean I don't know if
anybody's a guaranteed loss I mean I
feel like I trust him more than I do
Layton Vander Esch I like him better
than Layton Vander Esch but I'm I know
that there's certainly a lot of people
out there that don't just such a great
athlete they're not gonna go is there
any chance they go pass rusher here
David Irving and all of his issues that
Marcus Lawrence will be a free agent
after this season Kony Ealy Zoli being
signed on a one-year deal definitely
could go passer but then again I'm just
telling you that they're starting wide
receivers or Cole Beasley Terrance
Williams and Deonte Thompson and Allen
Hurns yeah but I just I am so done with
paranoid you run the ball and be that
type of team you don't really need well
know you have to have a difference-maker
at one receiver so DJ more because yeah
he's got it you got to do something to
go we have to scare them from putting
eight guys or nine guys in the box all
the time you have to have when when this
offense was really clicking what did
they do
Dez Bryant split out oh it's single
coverage I'll throw the Dez Bryant oh
you're doubling Dez will run the ball it
was really that formula so that's where
DJ more makes sense
I've seen the Cameron Sutton kid from
I'm not exactly Cortland sudden from SMU
yeah the other
corner alright so what's your final
guess is gonna be mine snowing evander
ish I'm gonna go I'm gonna go more I'm
gonna go more - what do you think I'm a
little mad you know I don't think that I
don't think it's offense I'm in I'm
gonna go with the wild card here and say
Courtland Sutton I think if I'm wrong
it'll be another defender they were
obsessed with Courtland sudden that his
pro day I mean I really thought they
were gonna be like kidding you I mean
I'm on that yeah yeah what can we expect
you fully oh so we're gonna play that
game I don't like try to get points bro
trying to get Rashad Evans points right
now it's funny as you could tell our set
is here at AT&T Stadium why go to Dallas
when you can chill in New York kids it's
not like 80 and there's barbecue man we
can get you some barbecue here let's go
to Brooklyn what do you think is if you
were their GM what would you do I would
take leighton vander as long as you pass
medically i know everybody's told you
don't feel the same way about Layton no
I do not feel the same way about Layton
especially in that scheme I'm a little
bit skeptical of it I understand the
special scream so tell me the mirror not
marinelli scheme what do they need yeah
I mean it's cover to cover three it's a
four times Lady Vanishes a bill I know
but they've never had that big time
middle linebacker they've always gone
for more of the true I think he's laid
up on weald I think yes yeah I don't
know I just I I'm not in love with the
guy overall I know been hurt a lot yes
I don't think he's plays overall
physical like you said he doesn't is
there any chance they go back to the
Michigan well after getting taco
charlton and go Maurice Hearst I think
the the clicker is a little bit of a
problem there guys yeah and I wouldn't
take him in the first round no I'm just
your Lane radius I know the cowboy is
there any chance that Jason Witten is
getting older and they're gonna go for a
heart hurdle for a go during it's way
too early this tight in class is deep so
you could give a market reason person
making the picks it's Jerry Jones you
got the copper Jason Garrett sit next is
will declare my injury is you know
because Dallas is a little like old
Oakland Raiders but I just go for the
past well look like I said before
DeMarcus Lawrence is a free Egypt of the
cheer so is David Irving David Irving
has had plenty of suspension issues the
other thing that's interesting is Zack
Martin and Chad's green or free agents
at the end of the year too
and they're trying to get a deal done
with Zack Martin yes I don't think he's
going anywhere now but that offensive
line sure did fall off quick from - you
know I've been saving like three weeks
on the podcast that this should be late
in vandura so maybe I'm actually to be
upset if it's not what are they just
gonna sit here and let the fanfare go on
forever Alice are you kidding me Jerry
Jones said they're going look for me
I'm seeing something but I don't want to
come I want a more legitimate person
look can you see me tell us what you're
seeing can you tell us who the
non-legitimate personal white boys
Supreme Lane Mandarin yes here's the pic
that's what the first one I saw I want
one more I don't call him out for not
being a reputable source who is it I
don't know no one's told me anything I
mean I know that he was way more
interesting right now martavis Bryant
just got traded what martavis Bryant
just got traded to the Raiders for their
third round pick of course they did I
was gonna say first of all the Raiders
yeah that's okay that's so Oakland I
mean I can't Darryl Worley a martavis
Bryant put them on the same team dude
but nothing about this Omari Cooper and
martavis Bryant with Jordy Nelson in the
middle that's prunes trying to do
something now yeah I just heard look at
the positive I just heard his vanish
it's vandura he's dangerous okay he's
good what do you guys think what are
grades on I gave him a hey they got the
corniest linebacker meeting room in the
end I'm just gonna give it a B Connor
okay
Miller you love Layton VIN I did yeah we
had him on the podcast he's a great
athlete he's an up side cast super super
smart swimmer Sean Evans here I would
have okay
yes definitely I I don't dislike Layton
Vander rush I was not overwhelmed with
his film as a whole I'm overwhelmed with
the prospects of the athlete and player
he can be but your issue is this people
would juice up games and you'd be like
okay he had 15 tackles but like 12 of
them were like how I ever did you watch
that organ game and I want to be what do
you mean when the Red Sea parted and
they just ran into his chest and they
had a tackle and I mean it was nothing
great this is why we're better than TV
TV's gonna make kids clap we're gonna
get
the pic let's do the video the lagunas
the draft was in Dallas and they need a
linebacker in the middle for Shaun Lee
and the future and they're going
Leighton van der s here Miller was all
over this kid from Boise State you loved
him you're a little bit more questioning
let's start off with the love I said
this was my guy in this strap not my
favorite player not my top-ranked
linebacker this is just my guy an
athlete in the middle of the field could
play weak side backer could play Mike so
good it was that's do a lot of different
things you see here he's asked to go
after the quarterback he was asked to
play up the seam a lot which I think
will be a great fit in their defense I
had him as my 19th overall player he
just went over to the Dallas Cowboys so
make me look smart Jerry appreciate it
and I know he's a physical specimen he's
a specimen he really is I mean he has
room to grow as a player in general and
he's gonna get bigger and thicker and
stronger yes when you watch him on the
field he's an incredible athlete can run
sideline to sideline like Jermaine
Edmunds he's gonna be a pain in the butt
to throw around in the middle of the
defense because of his size his length
you saw it dad a 39 and a half inch
vertical so yes he is made to stop the
pass as well but I did I had questions
about some of the things that I saw at
the middle linebacker position talked
about the fact that there were teams I
report there were five teams that failed
him medically because of a narrowing in
his spine the Cowboys lines they weren't
one of them because they felt
comfortable taking him here so I give it
an a man I think he is one of the better
players in the class a great fit for
them and just you're never gonna have to
worry about him they have to worry about
so many players on this team you're
never gonna have to worry late in June
yeah it's Kay he's watching film right
it's character I get that I do he is a
can't-miss from that standpoint I'm only
going to give this a B though from this
standpoint this guy as a middle
linebacker I'm not necessarily just
excited about it I don't think he just
he doesn't lay the wood he's not the
most physical middle linebacker I've
ever seen he's athletic yes certainly
but I would have rather of them taken
Rashad Evans if they wanted a middle
linebacker I think he was a better
player at the position that's why I give
it a big I think sometimes Jerry loves a
story this is a man that played
eight-man football and grew up in a town
in Idaho that had a population of 400
and now
he's wearing a star on his helmet no
matter what to hell of a story Leighton
Van Dhiresh the future at middle
linebacker for the Dallas Cowboys for
weak sides
okay so 20 Detroit has devoured
everything l will pick we're on anymore
has to be format Patricia no Matt
Patricia could go corner here yeah I
thought it could be corner two but what
else what else did you say I thought it
would be here Landry I'll tell you what
the reason however Landry makes a lot of
sense a lot of their pass rushers are up
for free agency next year whether it's
Ezekiel ants all those guys also they
haven't been great at getting after the
quarterback in recent years 20th and
sacks last year zekiel ons as a free
agent carry hiders gonna be a free agent
but I know I agree with Simms here
Patricia run that that Patriots defense
they they need corners and right now
it's Darius slay and then he's paired
with Nevin Lawson so I don't know so I
could see him I really don't let's go to
your big board here Harrell engine makes
the most plans makes no sense I liked
Connor Williams I know there's some
talking he might be a guard I think he
could play tackle I expect we'll hear
his name you get called tonight or
Harold Landry is definitely up there if
they go corner Josh Jackson is the best
on my board Mike Hughes I just worry
about the off field a little yeah I mean
I know I don't know I know a little bit
of the other stories Mike Hughes but
Mike Hughes man just from pure on the
field talent I mean he was my favorite
corner in the draft I really loved his
ability to Jam people of the line of
scrimmage his speed he played way to
astir than his four or five speed he
will be the best punt returner in
football next I was looking over the
Lions roster yeah I love what they've
done it linebacker
yeah I'm this offseason Jared Davis was
a homerun pick and you put Christian
Jones and Devon Canard next to him yes
this is a Lions team that would get
torched by running backs out of the
backfield every time I watch and now
look at those guys in the middle yeah
speed and speed right LeGarrette Blount
I saw what the Eagles he's not a feature
back but he's gonna give the hard nosed
running that Detroit hasn't had because
guess what they were in rushing last
year Sims
last like they are every freaking year
but but but Matthew Stafford is not very
good
oh I heard Carson Palmer on Leba [ __ ]
saying they said what quarterback do you
think has been hurt by a situation than
most it's Matt Stafford
yeah so I think that their offense is
pretty good I think that the offensive
law
I don't know if there's anyone worthy to
maybe help them out with guard play but
to me it's Landry or a corner and it
depends which corner they want it's your
gut telling you my gut would tell me
they would like a Mike Hughes that would
be that kind of place you see him as a
as an island type of climate he could be
like a better version of Malcom Butler
that he had so then you got Darius lay
on one side that could be you know his
Stephon Gilmore and Josh Jackson's a lot
like Malcolm Butler but that will be
we'll talk about that in the second
round when he Connor I know the pic is
gonna be in so you're gonna give it to
assume but what's your prediction man I
thought Landry is too good to pass up
here that's my thought process I want to
ask Simms is Patricia a guy that says we
need as many corners as possible because
New England operates them yeah I know I
do think that he is along those lines
that we're up Quinn the GM well yeah I
do think there are along the lines that
they want two corners they can trust
Amanda maybe I know I know
we got the pitch saber and it's not
Harold Landry and it's not corner
it's my guy Frank Ragna oh there you go
here our offensive lineman from Arkansas
okay they put a left guard so now the
offensive line will be Ricky Wagner TJ
Lang Graham Glasgow your man rag now and
then Taylor Decker that's amazing it's a
really good glass guys a better guard
than he will be a center so that's great
Swanson was hurt a spot that they needed
why do you like I disguise so much
Connor he's a powerhouse and absolute
powerhouse you talk about the best
anchor on the interior line I mean I'm
talking not as good as Quintin Nelson
but he's the next guy he's in that
Willie Hernandez powerhouse mode they
can open up the wrong game at both
levels and he doesn't get beat as a past
protector he doesn't his quarterback is
never put in the dirt when this guy
isn't you know playing now the problem
was he lost his entire season after
October and that's what this reminds me
of this reminds me of when the Patriots
took Logan Mankins yeah and we were
looking at different spots and they took
Logan Mankins and he anchored that line
it also kind of reminds me when Dallas
took Travis Frederick where it's like
man I said her now yeah but I think
we're past that error well tell me about
the medicals of this guy
yeah I don't know that he I think he's a
better guard than he is
Center you do yeah I think he's so
physical so that's where I would
probably I'm at but you're right the
medicals are an issue what was a foot
injury this year Connor I'm pulling my
notes up the foot injury for sure yeah
he missed the whole year
great right he couldn't eat couldn't do
the Senior Bowl yes you know not much at
the combine I suffered a seizure I left
ankle injury in October he tore every
ligament and required surgery is serious
yeah yeah yeah and that's why I actually
had him low I had an early round to
grade on him and it was because of
injury stuff and I I really thought
Billy price from Ohio State was better I
thought James Daniels from Iowa was
better a - yeah I'll give it a b-minus I
don't know this kid is damn impressive
when you watch the film he is we watch
this yeah because I'd only really
watched like a POA tape because I was
like yeah I don't think this guy's gonna
go in the first round he didn't play
last year so yes I did have to go back
and it's impressive I know we're gonna
get out of this but look we still got
Lamar Jackson no wide receivers have
been taken Y had heard receivers weren't
gonna go until if now Bengals might take
one Patriots might think yeah oh man
okay all right so we're gonna do Frank
rag now the new interior lineman for the
Detroit Lions
if you're a Detroit Lions fan you know a
few things and one of them is we haven't
helped out Matt Stafford nearly enough
we've been investing in first round
offensive lineman Taylor Decker's one of
them and now Frank rag now is gonna
enter the center kid from Arkansas not
everyone saw him play because right hurt
but what did you see when you watch the
film yeah I mean I loved his versatility
he started a left guard also played some
center he was a team captain for
Arkansas one of the things that you know
the Patriots guys like Quinn and
Patricia love now in Detroit
excellent athletic testing at the pro
day ideal size at 65 312 long arms at
three at 33 and 1/8 scheme versatile one
of the toughest guys in the entire draft
as well he finishes he has that right
mentality and before he got hurt this
year 33 games started I had him early
round two because of an injury though
that cost him almost the entire season
yeah the injuries scary but man the
film's not the films gonna be scary for
defenders because he's phenomenal he is
probably the best Center in the draft
for me I mean again to be 65 312 pounds
have those arms but the athlete he is at
the position you got to be twitchy to be
a center if you want to but block the
Fletcher Cox in the air in Donald's of
the world while also snapping the
football right you got to think about
that for a second his ability to get to
the second level and then Miller talked
about his anchor and pass protection
everything man he is he has Pro Bowl
potential as a center low so the Lions
are trying to do with the Patriots right
they got Bob Quinn they got a Tricia
who's working with the Patriots right
now Bret Bielema yeah that's right I
feel like the Lions kind of stole this
offensive lineman that Bielema coach
they know what's good what grade you
give I gave it a b-minus in the only
reason it's not because I don't like
Frank rag no I just like Billy price
from Ohio State and James Daniels from
Iowa better I understand the scheme fit
he's probably a little bit better at
point of attack in the power run game
but a little bit of a reach hey listen I
get that I this is the best Center for
me the other guys you're talking about
are extremely good I'm going to give
this an a-minus first of all hey you're
past protecting your franchise in the
quarterback and listen I don't care
who's that running back with some of the
offensive lines they put out there in
the past it doesn't matter you're not
gonna run anywhere there's no holes
Ragna is gonna bring them attitude okay
and he's extremely good in all phases of
the football game and if they had to
move in the guard they could do that
it's a good bet
Detroit Lions were the worst team in the
NFL last year of rushing they finally
are put in offensive line in front of
staffer and the boy the Lions are coming
watch out in the NFC North
[Music]